so who's ready welcome to the refuge
program I'm Garrett Conley I'm the
author of boy race now a major motion
picture
boy race is the story of my going into
conversion therapy after being outed to
you my parents and the psychological
torture that I endured while I was there
you cannot be born gay also it's a story
I think of my mom who takes me out of
therapy and saves my life and also has
to go on her own journey of acceptance
I'm just here to try to stop conversion
therapy because I wish I had done my
homework before I took him instead of
after I took him because it's a it's a
horrible thing and we need to get it
stopped conversion therapy has taken
many forms it's been around since the
19th century actually in the 1950s and
60s there was a hospital called Saint
Elizabeth's Hospital outside of
Washington DC they perform lobotomy as
they performed electroshock therapy they
had people in straightjackets at this
moment 36 states do not have bans on
conversion therapy for minors the bigger
battle however is that any religious
organization can perform conversion
therapy and charge for it currently no
matter what state you're in I mean I had
it pretty easy growing up we moved to a
place called Cherokee Village Arkansas
we'd always been very much a church
family that always been told that being
LGBTQ was not right and I don't think
there were any exceptions to that I
think that as I grew older and I started
to understand myself a lot more in my
sexuality it became obvious that I was
on a crash course with these two
ideologies being the you know married to
a Baptist pastor and being raised the
way I was we believed exactly what the
Bible said about homosexuality and
that's what I was taught and I just
didn't question it because I think you
don't tend to question things until it
hits your family or someone that you
love I was actually in my first semester
of college someone that I knew at the
time
[Music]
raped me and he confessed to me that
he'd also raped a fourteen-year-old boy
right after you he raped me confess this
to me and I told some friends what he'd
done and he found out that I'd told that
and so as a pre-emptive move he called
my parents called my mom specifically
because he really wanted it to strike
fear and it worked and when I came home
dad took me into his bedroom and said
like can you explain to me what's going
on
and so I told him I think I'm gay first
of all we took him to the doctor and had
his hormones checked you know that's how
naive we were then we called the largest
southern Southern Baptist Church in
Memphis and they said oh yes you're so
lucky we have a unit right here in
Memphis and it's called love in action
and they have an 84 percent pure rate
and I'm thinking wow you know I didn't
even know what conversion therapy was we
did one-on-one therapy sessions after I
was outed for about six months I went to
your residential program the main
activity that we did was called a moral
inventory and we were asked to write
down every sexual fantasy or experience
we'd ever had and we would have to say
it in front of everyone like share that
with everyone in the group and then
after that they would give me Bible
verses to sort of combat those thoughts
that I'd had I knew that if I didn't do
this I would lose my family my faith
perhaps my community by the end of the
second week I was asked to do this
exercise asking me to imagine my father
sitting there and basically say that I
hated him and I I remember thinking to
myself these are Christians who were
saying that in order to be cured I have
to hate someone not love someone and
Christ is all about love
how much repaid it was like $3,200 and
then we all just a really short period
yeah and then we also had to stay in a
hotel for two days his quote for you for
me going out for a year for doing eight
years of their how much was that well it
was like $21,000 now this may be the
toughest but most rewarding 12 days that
many of you who ever faced we later
found out that all the leaders I mean
none of them had more than a high school
education within a week they were
started talking to me about oh he's not
following the rules he's not doing his
homework right I think you need to put
him in the three
program and then you need to think about
keeping him out of school next year that
was just too quick it just got so phony
to me and they were like trying to
pressure me into signing him up and he
hadn't even been there a week yet so
who's ready
Victor Sykes in the film is based off of
John Schmitt who ran 11 action for many
years 22 years and after a while I don't
know if it's because of the negative
press or if it's because it got to his
conscience but he quit he stepped down
and once he stepped down he began a slow
journey of realizing that it was not
ever working that he was selling a lie
and then he married his now husband and
lives in Paris Texas making furniture it
just did such damage to me as well
because of the guilt that I feel for
taking him there you do it because you
think you're saving your child and you
love your child I don't want other
parents to have to go through the guilt
that I've had to go through for 14 years
I think the greatest value for this film
is its ability to show a road map for
people who are around LGBTQ youth to do
better and to act better and to become
better people through it and that's what
I hope the movie does
[Music]
you